okay let's go next to our caller from
the eight-six to area code who's calling
today from eight-six - does that mean
that is you who's this hello hi there
this is from New Jersey hey Sam what's
going on I just had a quick question
about your previous comments on like the
whole discussion about private so
private corporations like the social
media one than the the whole trumps
what's it his executive order thing yeah
you defended that so wait I defended
science executive order was doing that
was that what some is great
sorry miss misspoke the the private
companies how they have the right to
like you know host what they want on
websites if I'm if I'm misrepresenting
you sorry but I just wanted to kind of
like quickly remind you of what my
question seemed contextual so I had a
question about how you feel about their
targeted ads like specifically Instagram
and Facebook I don't know if you've
heard but it or or like experienced this
yourself but it almost seems like just
having a discussion with people around
like your phone or your computer you'll
go on to like Instagram and whatnot and
there will be targeted ads just about
things that you were discussing like say
I want like a new video game right or
something like that or anything along
those lines and I go on Instagram and
within five minutes I see an ad for
something like that yeah yeah this is
not I mean so let me talk about this a
little bit for people who so or I don't
think that this if my understanding is
that this is not the platforms that are
doing this so basically my under eye I
have a little bit of an understanding of
this I've tested this a number of times
so at one point I was thinking of
getting a particular sneaker and it's a
sneaker I'm not gonna say this sneaker
brand because they're not paying for ads
and it just doesn't really matter but
it's it's sort of Anadyr sneaker brand
so it's not like I had been saying the
name of it regularly and I mentioned it
to my girlfriend and then the next day I
got ads on Instagram for that sneaker
company um and as a test she said a
difference like I found an obscure
sneaker brand and we talked about it
she started getting ads for that sneaker
brand the next day same thing happened
with a Boston sports club that was
opening where we mentioned it and I
started getting ads for it so this is
happening but my understanding is that
this is not the social media platform
that is quote doing this that this is
information that is available for
advertisers to take advantage of when
they want to advertise on different
platforms so I'm just not sure that it's
accurate to say that that that's
something that Twitter is doing I think
this is a function of the way that you
have your phone configured I think it
has something to do with someone told me
if you turn Bluetooth Bluetooth off that
won't happen although that doesn't
totally make sense to me but yes I know
exactly what you're talking like a faux
solution to that but I don't see I don't
see how those two things could be
connected but yeah I guess my question
about it would be well whether it's
social media companies or not do you
feel like well because they are hosting
the ability to do that if it's not them
directly do they're allowing you to I
hire get on that basis for sure yeah I
would agree with that yeah do you do you
find that to be an intrusive thing or do
you think that that's that that's
allowed as something that a private
corporation should be allowed to do well
so again we have to distinguish what it
is that we are talking about
I find it intrusive and creepy I find it
intrusive and creepy on a personal level
now when you're granting our phones the
permissions required to do this the
strongest argument I've heard is we're
granting it without even really knowing
it because who really understands all of
those terms of service and the
permissions that you're granting your
phone yeah don't even read them exactly
exactly
but I find it absolutely creepy and
intrusive and now there's a counter
argument which is listen if you're gonna
see 10 ads a day no matter what isn't
everyone better off if they are more
targeted to your interests but that
seems to me sort of like a red herring
yeah okay and I just had one more quick
question if that's all right yeah um so
you have sort of not I wouldn't say
flippantly but because you know you say
you don't really do as much coverage for
the people polling at 1% but you've
stated prior that ending actually a
previous call you know
she doesn't really have a chance of
becoming the Democratic nominee and I I
agree I'm personally a Bernie supporter
so it's not like I'd be voting for her
anyway but in my humble opinion well
have a tumble but Bernie yang and Tulsi
are probably my top three even though
the latter two pretty much have no
chance okay at this point you know I
kind of agree with your assessment but I
want to know what your opinion is on the
fact that even though Tulsi you know
polled very low she met the donation
threshold and polled
well not well above but but enough on
plenty of polls that would otherwise be
considered legitimate if not for the
DNC's random you know requirements that
don't seem to that seem to be rather
obscure and I want to know what your
opinion is on that like should she have
been allowed in the debate like do you
think that those do you think that those
the polls that that cited her as having
polled above two percent should have
been taken seriously listen my opinion
it's sort of like whether whatever I
think about which polls should have been
included it wasn't a secret which polls
counted and it was known which polls
were counting long before it was known
who would meet the criteria in those
particular polls so like I think the DNC
does a lot of terrible stuff they are
gatekeepers in many ways that I find to
be destructive but the idea that after
seeing that if certain polls were
counted Tulsi would be in the DNC
decided we're only going to count other
ones that's just not the way that it
went that the polls that were counting
were decided ahead of time and it just I
I have a hard time feeling outraged
about it I do I wouldn't say I'm
outraged about it because I wasn't you
know I wasn't going to vote for her in
the first place because like I said I'm
I'm more of a Bernie supporter yeah I
guess I guess then you could back it up
from there and say you think that that
practice of only picking specific polls
which certainly favor the DNC preferred
candidates because you know there's
there's there's plenty of evidence that
they over vote over select you know
older voters etc and things like that
yeah I we've looked in detail at a lot
of the polls and most of them are not
over sampling older voters they are
accounting for the fact that older
voters are actually more like
to vote than younger voters and I think
that that's a completely legitimate
thing to consider but listen I mean the
the problem is if you have no standard
then anyone can just get a poll done you
can just purch you you know anyone can
can fund a poll and you can demand that
it be done in a certain way and then all
of a sudden it's like well there needs
to be some kind of line all right fair
enough
I understand that answer thank you very
much David I appreciate you taking my
question all right thank you appreciate
the phone call let's take a quick break
if you are on hold
don't hang up because we will go right
back to the phones after this